in collaboration with the Pointer
fellowship in journalism at Yale the
Frankie program is delighted to have
Ross Anderson the deputy editor at the
Atlantic magazine I would first like to
start by recognizing our benefactors
mr. and mrs. Richard and Barbara Frankie
for the generosity in endowing this
program that allows us to host these
events Ross Anderson was previously the
senior editor where he was overseeing
science and science technology and
health at the Atlantic before he became
the deputy editor and prior to joining
the Atlantic he was the deputy editor of
Aeon magazine which was a fully online
magazine that focused primarily on
science and Ross has written some
fantastic articles on space sciences
cosmology which is a key interest for
him as well as biology and he has
tackled the social implications of
Science and Technology in many of the
pieces that he's written he's looked at
a broad set of ideas sharing not just
the latest discoveries but also emerging
ideas and science and technology that
continue to strongly shape our world
science communication is something that
he has been very passionate about and in
this age of rampant denialism of science
it's extremely important that we as
scientists as intellectuals have in our
corner fantastic writers like him who
convey important discoveries the content
of these discoveries but also the
context of the work and are able to make
it accessible with real clarity he
studied at UC Irvine where he majored in
philosophy of science and I believe this
has deeply shaped his ability as well as
his desire to write at the intersection
of science and the arts and help bridge
these unnecessary so-called to culture
divides one of the nice things about
Ross is that he actually delves very
deeply into his stories and I remember
reading a story that he wrote about
cosmology in which he immersed himself
meeting cosmologists reading scientific
papers for almost six months before he
wrote that piece so there's that kind of
rigor so he has the mind of a scientist
with that kind of rigor and of course
writes beautifully which not all of us
scientists can and the reason I found
him really quite charming when I first
met him was that he said that one of the
things that's been really rough
recording an interview that he gave said
one of the things that's been really
refreshing in dealing with scientists as
opposed to say politicians or most
business people is that scientists are
wonderfully candid they're just firing
on all cylinders all the time because
their traffic and ideas and that's
what's important to them so you can see
it was very very easy to be totally
charmed when you know he's so fond of
your community and what you do so before
we before I invite Ross to talk to us
today where he's gonna talk to us about
writing at the intersection of science
and the art I just wanted to mention
upcoming Franke program events oddly
enough we have another writer writer
focused event on Wednesday this
Wednesday and we have the mathematician
turned novelist award-winning novel
Isaiah Heather Ramon and we'll be having
a conversation again on how the two
cultures shape imagination and
creativity and then as part of our
mapping and knowing lecture series on
March 31st we have the musicologist
Victor Coelho who has been mapping the
musical traditions across time and space
and I just wanted to alert you to one
event which is a distinguished lecturer
event which is on April 13 we have Susan
Hockfield who was the former Provost
Rafael and former president of MIT who
will be coming to speak to us and I just
wanted to remind you that we have this
video contest Eureka that is on and it's
open so please send in your entries to
describe any scientific concept without
using mathematics or jargon using a
video under two
minutes so this is a contest that we
have announced as part of the Frankie
program so without much further ado I'd
like to invite Ross all right I hope to
live up to that very generous
introduction get my notes up here okay I
have to start actually by apologizing
for a bit of false advertising a day
after I told Priya that we were gonna
call this talk writing at the
intersection of science and the arts I
realized that that title was was all
wrong the good news is the actual
substance of this talk is Hughes much
closer to the our generous hosts and
their mission here the Frankie program
because well I have done some writing
about the touch point between science
and the arts I want to talk today about
how we when we tell stories about
science how we situate science in sort
of the broader humanistic project we
have to and really the arts are part of
that project but they're only one part
of it we have to work hard to tell
stories in that way because in the
popular press scientists science itself
tends to be ghetto eyes scientists are
often depicted as kind of like this
nerdish sexless almost priestly class
when in reality as we know scientists
are complex flawed fully realized human
beings science is also deep politicized
and I don't mean with respect to climate
change or vaccines I mean that science
itself is political in the way that all
human endeavors are political you get to
know scientists not Priya but you
discover they're not all angelically
pure
moral truth-seekers they they take part
in feuds they jockey for power in their
respective fields and they have petty
jealousies and more important than that
the knowledge that scientists produce
isn't just nerdy trivia nor is it
strictly the means by which we get new
technologies science has implications
for the way we even think about
ourselves as human beings situated in
this grand cosmos and I think that the
the the humanity is the humanistic
disciplines art literature religion and
philosophy and much else ignore science
at their peril and so when we write
about Sciences at the Atlantic in lots
of places um we try to get to that whole
spectrum from the human messiness all
the way to kind of the grandeur of the
cosmos and I'm gonna try to say
something today about how we do that by
stepping through a few long-form essays
that I've written just to explain how
I've thought about them and some of the
choices I've made and I'll make that
concrete with some shorts ish readings I
guess by now you should realize that
you've done something very foolish in
inviting a writer to talk about his work
and to that point I want to stress that
there are really many ways to make
science come alive and to situate
science in the broader humanistic
project Carl Zimmer is in the audience
with us today and is quite good at it
himself and I'm only talking about the
way I do it
because it's the way I know best also
your forgive me I have no slides partly
out of incompetence and partly because
it makes me feel like a an old-fashioned
man of letters I want to start with an
essay that I wrote back in 2012 which I
have a great deal of nostalgia for
because it was the first long-form piece
that I wrote for publication and this
essay was nominally about the James Webb
Space Telescope which will serve as the
successor to the Hubble Space Telescope
provided that it ever launches back when
I wrote this piece the Webb
which as it's known was already
tremendously delayed but everyone was
sort of confident that it would go up by
2018 and now Priya will know better than
I do but if there's chatter that it
might not even lift off before 2021 but
actually gets a bit too why I wanted to
write about the web when you want to do
a science piece that folds in thinking
from a lot of different disciplines it
kind of helps to have a subject that
won't bite you on deadline and I knew I
wanted to write something sort of dreamy
and philosophical about the future of
astronomy and the web was this perfect
vehicle because it was Future II
obviously since it has yet to launch but
it it was just concrete enough that you
could kind of give it the mouthfeel of
reported journalism in thinking about
how to do that I realized fairly on that
I didn't want to zoom too far into the
tech extraordinary technical
capabilities of the telescope nor did I
want to get too far into the funding
fights and delays despite what I said
earlier about politics that had been
really well handled in a famous piece by
Lee Billings called the telescope that
eight astronomy I was much more
interested in situating the web in this
grand narrative and so instead of
siloing the piece in the field of
astronomy I ended up positioning it as a
sort of exciting new development in the
grand history of humans seeing human
vision and you can get a flavor of that
approach from the intro which I'll read
from now it's been a while the eye is
long been thought the jewel of human
anatomy in Mesopotamia fount of
civilization and astronomy Sumerians
worship small gods of clay and marble
featureless but for the stare of large
eyes the ancient Egyptians had several
different hieroglyphs for the eye in his
metaphysics Aristotle called seeing the
noblest Faculty of man not even
modernity has scrubbed the eye of its
metaphysical Sheen James Russell Lowell
dubbed it the notebook of the poet and
among the religious
mere existence is said to refute Darwin
yet for all of this tribute the human
eye remains a limited technology seeing
only the rainbow of visible light a thin
slice of the electromagnetic magnetic
spectrum and even this run in this realm
it falls short of other mammals for whom
nightfall is no curfew to have squinted
into the dark and seen the glimmer of
raccoon eyes is to have felt the chill
of this truth hence the human tool
makers had to compensate and vigorously
first by pouring new light into the
world with fire and electricity and by
dreaming up technologies to complement
the I like early stone tools these began
crudely chips of crystal unearthed and
shaped into small magnifiers in Rome
Nero was said to have peered through an
emerald at gladiators fighting in the
distance it would take until 1608 for
the telescope to be invented and another
year still until one was pointed at the
night sky light from the moons of
Jupiter fell down that telescope and
into the mind of Galileo who deduced
from it that not all heavenly bodies
circled the earth the first in a series
of fresh cosmologies rocked by the
telescope in the 19th century William
Herschel would use a large wooden
telescope to find and catalogue
thousands of nebulae single stars then
thought to be surrounded by clouds of
luminous fluid a century later at the
Mount Wilson Observatory Edwin Hubble
took a closer look at Herschel's nebulae
he discovered that Herschel had been
right in thinking that nebulae I
contained stars but that he was
seriously mistaken about the number we
now have a new word for nebulae galaxies
the 400 years since Galileo have marked
a revolution and seeing unlike anything
since the Cambrian explosion when light
sensitivity first rippled through the
food chain remaking it wholesale in that
time the telescope has divided and grown
mutating from a single modest tube to a
multitude of enormous landscape
dominating forms it is assumed the ways
of anesthetic leaving civilization from
our more solitary contemplative
environments deserts the shoulders of
volcanoes exotic islands even space
itself
the camera and the computer have given
the telescope a memory
freeing it from constant attachment to
the human
most importantly it has become a refined
deceit keen to the entire
electromagnetic palate including a
species of energy especially prized by
astronomers infrared light a telescope
sensitive to infrared light can see into
thick clouds where new stars and planets
lurk and in the chill of deep space
freed from the atmospheres distorting
shimmer an infrared telescope can see
nearly all of time in writing that piece
one of the things I wanted to do was
suggest that the achievements of the
telescope and specifically of the Hubble
Space Telescope were not yet appreciated
by the humanities the more I sat with
the Hubble the images that Hubble
produced the more I had this sense that
their philosophical implications had
only begun to be processed by the wider
culture at first I wanted to make a
straightforward argument to that effect
but everything that I tried to do just
read to dull or abstract so in the end I
tried to show not tell by dwelling at
some length on the local the total
marvelousness of the Hubble Deep Field
all of you will have seen Deep Field
images this is my only slide so get up
these are the ones where they point the
Hubble at some tiny region of the sky
for a period of days and it slowly
collects these faint layers of light and
at the end you get this really
far-reaching cosmic vista and my sense
is that while images like these have
been widely distributed we're still kind
of grappling with the awesome truths
that they communicate which I tried to
get at here said at first glance one
might mistake the Deep Field for
gemstones scattered across black velvet
but a closer look reveals that each
smudge of light 20600 at all is a galaxy
dense with billions of starfire worlds
pinwheeling a deep time before the
Hubble Deep Field astronomy at image
objects only four billion light-years
away and poorly at that here a telescope
reached 11 billion light years into
space and delivered a picture legible to
the laban an unprecedented expansion of
human vision much of the light caught by
the deep field traveled to the Hubble
from stars that burned out before the
earth had
even begun to form gazing at it is like
mainlining the whole of time through the
optic nerve like counting by fingertip
the tree rings of the universe from this
progression this cosmic vista new
notions about the evolution of stars and
galaxies have emerged historically
discoveries of pure science are slow to
reach the mainstream compared with those
of the Applied Sciences which noisily
announced themselves with new medicines
and gadgets the Hubble has proved an
exception remaining in a single
generation the popular conception of the
universe it has accomplished this
primarily through the esthetic force of
its discoveries which distill the
difficult abstractions of astrophysics
into the singular expressions of color
and light though philosophy is hardly
registered the Hubble has given us
nothing less than an ontological
awakening a forceful reckoning with what
is it compels the mind to contemplate
space and time on his shot on a scale
just shy of the infinite and in only 400
years it has transformed the night sky
from a decorative ceiling a fixed sphere
of glittering stick figure gods into a
universe whose reaches carry the seeds
of this earth and new earth still this
is one of the real privileges I think of
writing about the sciences which is
getting to frame its discoveries in a
way that might make people think
differently about the world they inhabit
but not all stories about science let
you sit in that mode of pure wonder the
next piece I want to talk about I did
for a london-based magazine where I used
to work a on magazine and it's called
the vanishing groves and tells a much
sadder story about the Bristlecone Pines
the world's oldest trees one of the
things we talked a lot about at the
Atlantic is that we need to work really
hard to tell conservation narratives in
new and compelling ways you should all
correct me if I'm wrong but it's my
sense that the public has really become
deadened to hearing about sort of the
endangered status of some beloved plant
or animal they kind of know all the
beats of those stories and all the
tropes and so there's a tendency for
them to read really worthy and yet
alerting the pub
to the fact that you know some of the
most precious natural phenomenon earth
are endangered as some of the most vital
work that we do as people who write
about Sciences about the sciences and so
it just takes our full creative powers
to sort of to do that in a way that
feels surprising I should admit by the
way that when I first thought about
writing about Bristlecone Pines that was
the full extent of my thinking was just
that I'd like to write about Bristlecone
Pines
and the magazine business we call that
having a topic and not a story but I
want to say a brief put it a brief good
word and four four topics because I
often find if you have time to develop
them that's sort of where you you know
your inner curiosity is most engaged and
you know with time you tend to find a
story sort of whether there's one there
at first glance or not with that said
please only ever pitch me completely
fleshed out stories anyway I became
obsessed with Bristlecone pines for a
while a lot of the writing that I've
done is about zooming out on long
timescales so a tree that lives up all
by itself in the high mountains and
lives for 4,000 years was just very much
my jam shortly after I started reading
up on the bristlecones I worried alright
I learned that they were imperiled by
climate change because a warmer climate
like many kinds of pine trees brings
bark beetles up to higher altitudes
where the bristlecones previously had
had the ground to themselves at that
point I already had this sense that
climate change threatening the world's
oldest trees was a pretty compelling
narrative on its own but I wanted to
bring in some other threads that made
this more distinctive what really
clicked into place for me was when I
figured out that or I didn't figure it
out when I learned quite late that
bristlecones are used in
dendrochronology which is the science of
tree rings which is actually how we get
many of our kind of baseline climate
records I knew I could make those two
things kind of talk to each other in a
way that would let me riff on the still
new idea of the Anthropocene
and that I'd kind of slowly discover it
in the writing in the end that get and
this gets very much to the science to
science and the humanities I position
the this loss of these trees is a loss
of cultural memory here's how I tried to
frame that in the intro of the piece
said no event however momentous leaves
an everlasting imprint on the world take
the cosmic microwave background the
faint electromagnetic afterglow of the
Big Bang it hangs reassuringly in every
corner of our skies the firmest evidence
we have for the giant explosion that
created our universe but it won't be
there forever in a trillion years time
it's going to slip beyond the cosmic
light horizon the outer edge of the
observable universe the universe's
expansion will have stretched its
wavelength so wide that it will be
undetectable to any observer anywhere
time will have erased its own beginning
on earth the past is even quicker to
vanish to study geology is to be
astonished at how hastily time reorders
our planet's surface filling its craters
smoothing its mountains and covering its
continents in seawater life is often in
the fastest to disintegrate in this
constant churn of water and rock the
speed of biological decomposition
ensures that only the most geologically
fortunate of organisms freeze into stone
and become fossils the rest is all into
sediment leaving the thinnest of
molecular traces behind part of what
separates humans from nature is our
striving to preserve the past but we too
have proved adept at its eraser it was
humans after all who set fire to the
ancient Library of Alexandria whose
hundreds of thousands of Scrolls
contained a sizeable fraction of
classical learning the loss of knowledge
at Alexandria was said to be so profound
that it set Western civilization back
1,000 years some have even described the
libraries burning as an event horizon a
boundary and time across which
information cannot flow the burning of
books and libraries has perhaps fallen
out of fashion but if you look closely
you will find its spirit survives at
another distinctly human activity one is
old as civilization itself
the destruction of forests
trees and forests are repositories of
time to destroy them as to destroy an
irreplaceable record of the Earth's past
over the last century of unprecedented
deforestation a tiny cadre of scientists
has roamed the world's remaining
woodlands searching for trees with long
memories trees that promise science a
new window into antiquity to find the
trees memories you have to look past its
leaves and even its bark you have to go
deep into its trunk where The Chronicles
of its long life lie secret it away like
a library's lost Scrolls this spring I
journeyed to the high dry mountains of
California to visit an ancient forest
a place is dense with history as
Alexandria a place where the heat of a
dangerous fire is starting to rise a lot
of this Bristlecone piece covers the
intricacies of these extraordinary
organisms the little kind of biological
technologies that allowed them to live
and thrive for so long but and this gets
to bringing the humanities to bear on
the sciences I also tried to bring
different modes of perception to bear on
these trees and on forests more broadly
this is something that's become a bit of
a theme in my work so much so that I
figure it's kind of verging on a stick
but whenever I write about phenomenon
nature I try to resurrect the pre
scientific view of the phenomena to try
to give a larger sense of how the human
mind is interacted with things like
trees or stars or elephants or whatever
across time
that way when we try to say what these
things mean to us today we're not
pretending that we started with a blank
cultural state that's late we're
consciously in dialogue with the
meanings these phenomena previously had
in human culture so for instance when I
take the reader on a hike through a
remote Bristlecone forest I make sure to
pause to go into the following
digression this experience of openness
and sublimity among the bristlecones is
at odds with fundamental Western ideas
about forests ideas that might have
something to do with our particular our
peculiar animosity towards them indeed a
suspicion than forests as dark shadowy
places is written into the basic Texas
of Western culture in Greek mythology
Dionysus the ivory wreath
god of the wooded glens threatened
civilization with a return to
animalistic primitivism in the Old
Testament Yahweh commands Hebrews to
burn down sacred groves wherever they
find them Christian culture has had
traditionally identified the forest as a
pagan stronghold a gloomy haven for
witches and outlaws in Dante the forest
is demon haunted and evil it's the
underworld
world out of which the hero must descend
for Descartes the forest is the
precursor to the Enlightenment the
physical embodiment of confusion the
maze that light beams of Reason must
penetrate the Stanford literary critic
robert polk harrison suggests that at a
subconscious level we resent for us for
their antiquity their antecedents to
humans harrison traces the human dread
of forests to the origin myths of sky
gods like jove who first announced his
existence to humans by sending lightning
into primeval forests he did this to
clear a hole in the tree canopy to open
up the mute closure of foilage as he put
it so that humans could see the sky for
what it was a divine entity a sender of
some signs a source of revelation about
our origins in our destiny
wherever divinity has been identified
with the sky or with the eternal
geometry of the stars or with cosmic
infinity or with heaven forests become
monstrous because they hide the prospect
of God I was grateful that that
bristlecones story got me thinking in a
mythic way about climate change because
in early 2016 I had after I'd moved to
the Atlantic I once again had the tall
order of making a climate change story
compelling for readers by the way that
sentiment about climate change stories
being sort of boring for readers is
starting to look a little outdated one
of the most kind of encouraging media
trends that I've had the privilege to
watch up close as the real genuine
uptick and reader interest in climate
stories
which is encouraging used to be more of
the sort of eat your vegetables reading
also if you will indulge me a plug
people often think of the Atlantic as
kind of a strictly political magazine
and to some extent that's right I mean
we were founded as a magazine of
abolition and we've continued to make
politics a central editorial interest
but of course science can't be corn
quarantined from politics and when you
look back in our archives you'll see
that science has been a preoccupation
from our earliest years I a cigar a
published the first full throated
American defense of Darwinism in the
pages of the Atlantic John Muir famously
made the case for the national parks in
the Atlantic and so when we write about
Sciences in the magazine we try to take
part in that rich lineage actually had
John Muir in front of mind when I took
on this climate rate related story I'm
going to tell you about which is about a
place called Pleistocene Park which is
like a national park but with its
ambitions turned up to 11 Pleistocene
Park is actually a geoengineering scheme
cooked up by Russian father-son
scientists who are trying to transform
the Siberian high Arctic by among other
things resurrecting woolly mammoths just
in that sentence you can tell there's a
lot going on which raises raised one of
the kind of fundamental difficulties of
writing this piece which was weaving all
the explanatory work into the narrative
of a first person visit to Siberia
without losing propulsion I started the
piece kind of in scene with me riding
along with one of the Russian scientists
and this like tank like all-terrain
vehicle at which point he started
crashing directly into trees to knock
them down so sort of good place to
introduce the reader into the narrative
but I knew to make this an Atlantic
story I had to quickly pivot to the
larger climate stakes and also getting
back to that theme of deep time put the
reader in a more expansive headspace so
here's how I tried to do that
human history began in the Pleistocene
many behaviors that distinguish us from
other species emerged during that 2.6
million year epoch when glaciers pulsed
down from the north pole at regular
intervals in the flood myths of Noah and
Gilgamesh and in plato's story of
Atlantis we get a clue as to what it was
like when the last glaciation ended and
the ice melted and the Seas welled up
swallowing coasts in Islands but human
culture has preserved no memory of an
oncoming glaciation we can only imagine
what it was like to watch millennia of
snow pile up into ice slabs that pushed
ever southward in the epic poems that
compressed generations of experience a
glaciation would have seemed like a
tsunami of ice rolling down from the
great white north one of these ten
thousand year winters may have inspired
our domestication of fire that's still
an equal technological leap that warmed
us warded away predators and cooked the
calorie dense meals that nourished our
growing brains on our watch fire evolved
quickly from a bonfire at the center of
camp to industrial combustion that
powers cities whose glow can be seen
from space
but these latter fossil fueled fires
give off an exhaust one that is pooling
invisibly in the thin shell of air
around our planet warming its surface
and nowhere is warming faster or with
greater consequence than the Arctic
every Arctic winter is an ice age in
miniature in late September the sky
darkens and the ice sheet across atop
the North Pole expands spreading a
surface freeze across the seas of the
Arctic Ocean like a cataract dilating
over a blue iris in October the freeze
hits Siberia's north coast and continues
into the land sandwich in the soil
between surface snowpack and
subterranean frost when the spring Sun
comes it melts the snow but the frozen
underground layer remains nearly a mile
thick in some places this Siberian
permafrost extends south through the
tender Tundra moonscape and well into
the taiga forest that stretches like an
evergreen stripe across Eurasia s
midsection similar frozen layers lie
beneath the surface in Alaska and the U
and all are now beginning to thaw
Pleistocene Park is meant to slow the
thawing of the permafrost for decades
the sea moths and their animals have
stripped away the region's dark trees
and shrubs to make way for grasslands
research suggests that these grasslands
will reflect more sunlight than the
forests and scrub they replace causing
the Arctic to absorb less heat in winter
the short grass and animal trampled snow
will offer scant insulation so that the
seasons freeze can reach deeper into the
Earth's crust cooling the frozen soil
beneath and locking one of the world's
most dangerous carbon dioxide loads into
a thermodynamic vault to test these
landscape cooling effects Nikita will
need to import the large herbivores of
the Pleistocene he's already begun
bringing them in from far-off lands two
by two as though filling an ark but to
grow his ice age lawn into a biome that
stretches across continents
he needs millions more he needs wild
horses musk oxen reindeer bison and
predators to corral the herbivores into
herds and to keep the trees beaten back
he needs hundreds of thousands of
resurrected woolly mammoths so I try not
to tell readers what to think but one of
the first thoughts you should have upon
hearing or reading that passage is
that's crazy and will that ever work and
that's a good question and it's a
question that is the proper domain of
science journalism and one that I tackle
at some length in this piece but to me I
guess like the more time I spent in
Siberia and sort of turning this over in
my head
Pleistocene Park became much more
interesting as a cultural project like a
lot of people I have this sense that
even in our post-enlightenment age
humans are going to continue to embed
themselves in kind of grand scale mythic
narratives and as a writer I'm really on
the lookout for emergent ones and in
this case the scientists had this view
which is still contested but kind of
slowly hardening into consensus I'd say
that this Arctic biome and along with
much of the planet had been utterly
transformed
after humans rampaged across the planet
and killed most of the megafauna that
live upon it
so to recap you have this father and son
in this far-off landscape they're trying
to save the world by red resurrect
resurrecting the most charismatic of the
extinct charismatic megafauna to me that
was just so obviously a mythic story and
so I stopped seeing the resurrection of
the mammoth is just like a necessary
step in the climate science mitigation
project and instead saw it as an attempt
at redemption at a time when we're kind
of renegotiating our relationship to
nature
I found that sort of so haunting and
poignant that I tried to get that across
in the closing of the piece which I'll
read now said before I left to catch a
plane back to civilization I stood with
Sergei on the mountaintop once more
taking in the view he had slipped into
one of his reveries about grasslands
full of animals he seemed to be
suffering from a form of solastalgia a
condition described by the philosophical
ossifer Glenn Albrecht as a kind of
existential grief for a vanished
landscape be it a swallowed Coast a
field turned a desert or a bygone
geological epoch he kept returning to
the idea that the wild planet had been
interrupted midway through its grand
experiment its 4.5 billion year blending
of rock water and sunlight he seemed to
think that the earth peaked during the
Ice Age with the grassland ecologies
that spawned human beings he wanted to
restore the biosphere to that creative
summit so it can run its cosmic
experiment forward in time he wants to
know what new wonders will emerge maybe
there will be more than one animal with
a mind he told me I don't know whether
Nikita can make his father's mad vision
a material reality the known challenges
are immense and there are likely many
more he cannot foresee but in this brave
new age when it is humans who make and
remake the world and as a comfort to
know that people are trying to summon
the whole landscapes Lazarus like from
the tomb
come forth they're saying to wooly
mammoths come into this habitat that has
been prepared for you join the wolves
and the reindeers and the reindeer and
the bison who survived you slip into
your old Ice Age
ecology wander free in this wild stretch
of the earth your kind will go stronger
as the centuries pass this place will
overflow with life once again our
original sin will be wiped clean and if
in doing all this we save our planet and
ourselves that will be the stuff of a
new mythology I'm conscious that I've
been doing sort of a lot of reading at
you this afternoon and so and I want to
save time for questions but before I
close I want to talk about my most
recent Atlantic feature I say most
recent but actually I mean most recent
most recently published I'm working on
another one right now that I'm just
entering closing on which means I don't
want to talk about it all in fact hope
to not talk about it for another year so
this piece I published last year and
it's called a journey into the animal
mind and it's about animal consciousness
a subject that I'd been hoping to write
about for some time and I started it by
pret by casting a pretty wide net trying
to sort of gather up as many sort of
sparkly animal cognition studies and
anecdotes that I could find in order to
build a sweeping case that it was time
to reconsider the question of whether
animals have an inner life I found that
process really satisfying research being
the best part of writing because you
don't have to write but as I started to
think through possible structures and
writing approaches for this piece every
way that I imagined doing it seemed
really conventional for instance I
thought of doing that sort of lab to lab
thing you know it's like oh I'm at the
dolphin lab you know or I'm at the
primate lab and you know lo and behold
all these these creatures are so smart
but my sense was that I'd be sort of
frog marching readers through a
structure like that and that you know
one of the healthy disciplines of
working at a general interest magazine
as opposed to a like somewhere like
Scientific American that were you know
there's sort of an assumed interest on
the part of the reader that science is
interesting is that you know my readers
can like flip to the next feature which
might be a true-crime yarn or
a piece by my colleague Graham wood is
in the back of the auditorium I'm
delighted to embarrass and so we really
have to work to sort of keep keep reader
interest in my experience when you're
stuck on your approach to a story it's
sort of the best thing you can do is
keep reading but in a in at least for me
it's a sort of specific kind of reading
which is a I think of it as kind of a
widening of the intellectual lens and
being someone who's interested in the
history of ideas in this case I did that
I did that extra reading more about the
history of thinking about animal
consciousness and in doing so I started
to learn about Jainism an ancient
religion on the Indian subcontinent
among other places whose practitioners
had been sounding the alarm about animal
consciousness and its implications for
human moral life for some three thousand
years when I hit upon that it gave me
the idea that if my editor did not think
it was completely insane
I can nest all this sort of cutting-edge
scientific research inside the
first-person experience of a Jain
pilgrimage in India here's how I it's a
difficult thing to communicate I can I
can confide it's a difficult thing to
communicate to the reader and the
introduction of a piece that this is
what's going to happen so here's what we
tried to do that said no aspect of our
world is as mysterious as consciousness
state of awareness that animates our
every waking moment the sense of being
located in the body that exists within a
larger world of color sound and touch
all filtered through thought and imbued
by emotion even in the secular age
consciousness retains a mysterious
veneer is alternatively described as the
last frontier of science and a kind of
immaterial magic beyond Sciences
reckoning David Chalmers
one of the world's most respected
philosophers on the subject once told me
that consciousness could be a
fundamental feature of the universe like
space time or energy he said it might be
tied to the diaphanous indeterminate
workings of the quantum world or
something non-physical altogether these
metaphysical accounts are in play
because scientists have
yet to furnish a satisfactory
explanation of consciousness we know the
body's sensory systems beam information
about the external world into our brain
where it's processed sequentially by
increasingly sophisticated neural layers
but we don't know how those signals are
integrated into a smooth continuous
world picture a flow of moments
experienced by a roving locus of
attention a witness as hidden Hindu
philosophers call it in the West
consciousness was long thought to be a
divine gift bestowed solely on humans
Western philosophers historically
conceived of non-human animals is
unfeeling automatons even after Darwin
demonstrated our kinship with animals
many scientists believe that the
evolution of consciousness was a recent
event they thought the first mine
sparked awake sometime after we split
from chimps and bonobos in his 1976 book
the origin of consciousness and the
breakdown of the bicameral mind
Julian Jaynes argued that it was later
still he said the development of
language led us like Virgil into the
deep cognitive states capable of
constructing experiential worlds now
each year brings a raft of new research
papers which taken together suggest that
a great many animals might be conscious
it was likely more than a half billion
years ago that some seafloor arms race
between predator and prey roused Earth's
first conscious animal that moment when
the first mine winked into being was a
cosmic event opening up possibilities
not previously contained in nature there
now appears to exist a long time
alongside the human world a whole
universe of vivid animal experience
scientists deserve credit for
illuminating if only partially this new
dimension of our reality but they can't
tell us how to do right by the trillions
of minds with which we share the Earth's
surface that's a philosophical problem
and like most philosophical problems it
will be with us for a long time to come
apart from Pythagoras and a few others
ancient Western philosophers did not
hand down a rich tradition of thinking
about animal consciousness but Eastern
thinkers have long been haunted by its
implications especially the Janes who
have taken animal consciousness
seriously as a moral matter for nearly
three thousand years
as perhaps the world's first culture to
extend mercy to animals the Jains
pioneered a profound expansion of the
human moral imagination the places where
they worship intend to animals seem to
me like good places to contemplate the
current frontier of animal consciousness
research now all along when I was
imagining how to structure this piece
even when I was thinking about going lab
to lab I thought that I would go from
sort of like start as close to humans on
the tree of life as possible and kind of
go further and further away so from
mammals or primates you know on to birds
and then fish and then ultimately ending
in insects where I think that that's as
far as pretty as like remote as you can
get from humans on the tree of life and
still have some some compelling evidence
of an inner life but I had to now think
about how to do that in India and like
to weave it together with the Jains so I
had to like go have Jane experiences
that would bring me into like some
animal encounters that could you know
with some writing trickery like be made
to serve this larger argument and I
really wanted as part of this to go see
the Asiatic lions which are a really
rare big cat species there's less than
600 of them in the world some people
don't know there's lions in India in
Gujarat actually and so I went I went to
see them they also were very useful for
my purposes because they play a role in
Jain mythology and I went to see him
have this like great time a couple days
in Gujarat like I went out with like the
head of the forestry department like in
the jeeps in the backcountry going
hunting lions and I got back and just
like that wrote the hell out of that
section of the piece like to the tune of
like sort of four or five thousand words
and I turned to my editor along with the
larger piece and he's like yeah you know
people know cats are conscious we live
with them just kind of obvious not that
surprising I think you just got the full
line section and which was extremely
extremely district distressing but also
unimpeachable that's logic we had this
kind of long bargaining phase where
I kept serve being like well you know
what if we cut it down to like 2,000
words you know and and kept trying to
like show him permutations of that
section that could possibly be included
but alas the final cut did did not
contain it I I still have the line
section of my personal file so and I'm
now going to read it just kidding no I
want to read a short passage about fish
from one of the sections that did
survive my editors invert it in
interventions just to give you a sense
of how I tried to weave together the
scientific material with the Jainism for
context at this point in the piece I've
just sort of finished making the point
that the experience of pain which is a
conscious experience is something more
than the detection of damage which is
something that even bacteria do I say
fish have many more kinds of damaged
sensors than bacteria do their sensors
flare when the water temperature spikes
when they come into contact with
corrosive chemicals when a hook rips
through their scales and into their
flesh in the lab when trout lips are
injected with acid the fish do not
merely respond at the site they rock
their entire bodies back and forth
hyperventilating rubbing their mass
against the cool glass of their tanks a
behavior that ceases when the fish are
giving morphine the experiences of these
lab fish are grim and possibly unethical
but they're nothing compared with those
endured by the trillions of aquatic
animals that humans yank unceremoniously
out of oceans and rivers and lakes every
year some of those fish are still alive
hours later when they're shoveled into
the sickly let refrigerated intake tubes
of the global seafood supply chain fish
pain is of course something different
from our own pain in the elaborate
mirrored Hall that is human
consciousness pain takes on existential
dimensions because we know that death
looms and grieve for the loss of richly
imagined futures it's tempting to
imagine our pain is the most profound of
all suffering but we would do well to
remember that our perspective can make
our pains easier to bear if only by
giving it an expiration date when we
pull a less cognitively blessed fish up
pressure depth and barometric trauma
fills its bloodstream with tissue
burning acid it's on deck thrashing
might be a silent scream born of the
fishes belief that has entered a
permanent state of extreme suffering the
Janes tell a story about a man from deep
antiquity who is said to have been
sensitive to the distress calls of other
animals his name is Naimah naav and he
is said to have developed this unusual
fondness for animals while tending
cattle on the banks of the yamuna river
in his home village of Sharper which i
reached four hours after leaving delhi
M&F is one of 24 Jane ford makers profit
like figures whose life stories tend to
emphasize their nonviolent natures one
is said to have floated perfectly still
in the womb sending not so much as a
ripple through the amniotic fluid to
avoid harming his mother the Jane's say
Neman off left Shari purr for good on
the day of his wedding that morning he
mounted an elephant intent on riding it
to the temple where he was to be Wed on
the way he heard a series of agonized
screams and demanded to know their
origin Neman oz elephant guide a man who
had reason to know something about
animal consciousness explained that the
screams came from animals that were
being slaughtered for his wedding feast
this moment transformed them enough some
versions of the stories say he freed the
surviving animals including a fish that
he carried in his hands back to the
river
others say he fled all agree that he
renounced his former life rather than
marry his bride he set out for Garner a
sacred mountain in Gujarat Gujarat 40
miles from the Arabian Sea so the final
section of this piece and of this talk
follows my own ascent up this sacred
mountain in Gujarat where I encounter a
wasp and after some riffing about it's
likely cognitive capacities climb up to
the top to take part in a Jain ritual I
want to close the talk with a passage
from it because it's a place where I
really tried my hardest you can tell me
I not sure I succeeded but to achieve
that synthesis that I talked about
earlier
that sense of sort of situating a
scientific idea and the broader
humanistic project and I say that
because the key thing to me about this
story was that the that the science was
being put in service of larger questions
questions posed by the humanities that
are actually prior to science and a
really important sense and so in the end
it was fitting that the scientific
aspects of this story were subordinate
in the storytelling to the philosophical
and even mythic aspects of it which are
all about human meaning here's how it
ends when the monk arrived at the wall
where I was resting the wasps flew away
rising up towards the Sun until I lost
it in the light the monk was wearing a
white mask like those that some Jane's
wear to avoid inhaling insects and other
tiny creatures I nodded to him as he
passed and lay back against the warm
stone of the mountain the monk was a
white dot some Switchback some six
switchbacks up by the time I hopped off
the wall and continued the climb my legs
stiffened by the break I reached the
entrance to the temple complex with only
15 minutes to spare it's marble
courtyards shone brilliant white as
though bleached by the mountains Sun
ducking under a row of elegant golden
medallions I entered the temple's
interior chamber where dozens of candles
flickered an intricately carved in all
wall niches and on platforms that hung
from the ceiling on chains the stone
ceiling was carved into a lotus flower
it's delicate unfurling petals
symbolizing the emergence of a pure
ethereal soul from the Earth's muddy
materials forty Janes were sitting on
the floor and neat rows their legs
crossed in the lotus position the women
wore fresh saris they carried up the
mountain for the occasion the men were
dressed in all white I wedged into a
spot in the back we faced a dark tunnel
like space lined by two sets of columns
at the far end candlelight illuminated a
black marble statue of the seated male
figure its barrel chest was inlaid with
gemstones as were its eyes which
appeared to float serenely in the dark
inducing a hypnotic effect broken only
when the man sitting next to me tugged
my shirt Neman off he said nodding
towards the statue it was here on this
mountain that Neman off is said to have
achieved a state of total unimpeded
consciousness with perceptual access to
the entire universe including every kind
of animal mind Jaynes believed that
humans are special because in our
natural state we are nearest to this
experience of enlightenment among
Earth's creatures no other finds it so
easy to see into the consciousness of a
fellow being the pilgrim started singing
first in a low hum and then steadily
louder one wielded giant drum next to
the tunnels entrance and struck it with
a dark mallet to others bashed cymbals
together men and women walked in from
opposite doors
converging in two lines on either side
of the tunnel a woman wearing an orange
sari and a gold crown crossed in credit
in front of Neman auth listed lifted a
vessel over his black marble head and
poured on a mixture of milk and blessed
water when she finished a white robe man
from the other line did the same the
singing grew louder until it verged on
the ecstatic
the pilgrims raised their arms and
clapped overhead faster and faster a
climax seemed to loom but then it all
dropped away the drums and the bells and
the cymbals went quiet leaving a clear
sonic space that was filled by a final
blow on a conch the shells low note was
long and clean it rang out of the temple
and over the ancient Peaks as it trailed
off I wondered whether in the centuries
to come this place might become
something more than a Jain house of
worship maybe it will become a place to
mark a moment in human history when we
awakened from the long dream that we are
the only minds that Nature has brought
into being maybe people will come here
from all corners of the earth to pay
their respects to Neman of--the who is
after all only a stand-in for whoever it
was who first heard animal screams and
understood their meaning that's it thank
you
[Applause]
happy to take questions look like
there's looks like there's tie is
holding a roving microphone right there
mine is just very quick from the very
first moment you started talking about
the Hubble and what could be seen into
the far far many eons ago until the
ending when you talked about the first
recollection or understanding of the
conscious mind through all the yawns
what brought to mind was young and the
collective unconscious for some reason
so I just throw it out there yeah I
don't I don't know what to say except
that I I do think young is really
interesting and that he obviously was
engaged much deeper in that practice of
thinking about how phenomenon nature are
sort of interpreted by the mind and
interpreted historically by many
different cultures and I find that sort
of endlessly fascinating so I share your
interest you talked about how you're
concerned with the philosophical
implications of science and scientific
discoveries in society and how you would
like to encourage your reader to grapple
with the awesome truths and forceful
reckoning that comes along with that
without trying to tell them what to
think and you talked about introducing
different modes of perception and that
makes me think about how a lot of what
what I read and what I hear talking
about sort of ancient and indigenous and
spiritual concepts that Western science
is now starting to put language to and I
see what you're writing is is kind of a
creative mayor marrying marriage of that
and so my question is do you see science
and spirituality as kind of two sides of
the same coin that's a tough one that I
will plead no I'm not sure that I can
answer entirely
I'm not I think I I guess I would be
very boring and say that you know
spirituality sort of means a lot of
different things to a lot of different
people I think that there's certainly
some spiritual relations to sort of
human life on this planet that I are not
only compatible but would sort of clear
quite significant space for science and
its kind of truths act seeking apparatus
to inform their engagement with human
life on this planet and so I certainly
don't think they're opposed and I find
spirituality is for my purposes like
when it comes to this piece on Jainism
or some of the stuff around
deforestation is often just like a
really good distillation of some of the
most interesting philosophical thinking
that was taking place two three four or
five thousand years ago and so I think
it's like just a fascinating place to
kind of mind the intellectual history of
people's approaches to some of these
issues your your subjects as a writer
seem so varied I'm wondering if you
perceive an underlying theme or
commonality to the stories you've
tackled that something that made you say
at the time this is my kind of story mmm
yeah deep time is definitely sort of one
that kind of shows up in almost
everything I write I'm it really
interested in kind of intellectual blank
spots on the map the unknown so like you
know when it comes to the far reaches of
cosmology life or intelligence elsewhere
in the galaxy it's really interesting
you know what we can know about other
animal Minds which you know to a large
extent will always be to some degree
fundamentally mysterious I mean it's I
don't know what's happening in your mind
and so I yeah I'd say the unknown has a
really kind of powerful pull for me it's
sort of combining your experiences as a
writer and also as an editor and also
you're talking about having to just
throw out four
words about lions I feel your pain and
I'm wondering I mean there's been such a
pressure a long-term pressure like I'd
say over the past 20 years in terms of
the size and scope of stories you know
like can we make this shorter and like
everything you're talking about is it
has to be big so how what's your do you
feel like readers of the Atlantic and
other things still can sustain that
attention in this environment or what's
your view on big stories yeah look I
mean it's like if you look at every year
shark beat I really hate to go into sort
of the kind of grim intricacies of the
media business here this talk about
cosmology and so forth but every year
chart beat puts out a list of the most
engaging stories of the year and I'll do
a brag for the home team that we've had
three three of the last five years the
most engaging story has been an Atlantic
story and every one of them has been a
long-form story one of them was actually
beerus Graham again was written by
Graham is in the back and I you know I
think there was this weird not to get
too nuanced on it but there was a kind
of a rediscovery of long-form by the
internet that happened maybe around what
2011 2012 where everyone sort of got
Precious about it and you know psych all
long reads and long-form and which were
tried to really cram a lot of stories
that maybe didn't deserve that treatment
into that form and so you ended up with
I got a lot of kind of pretty dry sort
of kind of play-acting long-form maybe
that tell you all felt felt during my
long reading this by the way and then I
I think there's now been a correction
back where you know partly due to some
sort of factors around scarcity in the
media business in general they're just
fewer of these kind of slots for super
long stories that have this
comprehensive approach which is on one
hand unfortunate on the other hand is
producing what's maybe a beneficial
selection effect but
I guess their jury's out on that
question but look I I wish I mean there
was a that that time sort of seven eight
years ago when you had lots of start up
digital magazines that were doing tons
of long-form YK on I mean there's still
under kin
Nautilus I guess is kind of alive and
maybe I don't know it seems like there's
still there's still a few of them but it
did seem like it was a time of a real
kind of creative profusion around
long-form that's kind of dwindled a
little for better or worse
hi so it seems like historically the
orientation or the the relationship
between journalism and science has
journalism has traditionally taken a
celebratory you know stance towards
towards journalism as you noted of
course science is political we pay pay
money to study one thing and not the
other there's plenty of infighting I'm
curious to hear how you think or how I
guess the Atlantic or your work
experience
approaches the need or the question of
how much critical science journalism
there should be whether the whether the
institution actually has the capacity to
do enough of it given what people are
interested in and all the wonders throw
I mean the universe is amazing there's
so many wonderful things to write about
and so how you balance how you think
about balancing that need for more kind
of journalism there would reflect almost
like a political journalism yeah
it's a great question we certainly don't
think about it in terms of like a pie
graph you know like ooh 30 percent
investigative you know stories to point
out scientists being bad Oh some of that
but we are kind of principally a
magazine of ideas so our you know we
recently ran a
a story last year about the N Cretaceous
extinction and sort of the long-running
scientific feud at the heart of that
that got a little bit into the politics
of science but through a larger
narrative that was about big ideas and
that's kind of the vector that the
Atlantic is usually going to go on and
on when we do something about science at
feature-length fortunately our media is
still robust enough that there are other
outlets who kind of special like look
the BuzzFeed science desk we can't say
enough good things about them as to in
terms of calling to account kind of both
sexual harassment and and malfeasance of
any number of kinds in the scientific
community it's not the first role of the
Atlantic but I think it's more that when
we tell deep stories about science we
want to have that kind of human and
political texture kind of throughout the
piece that makes sense I guess I just
wanted to say thanks to Ross and also
remind you all that he recently wrote
this really beautiful piece about Kobe
Bryant and sort of the mixed legacy so I
really recommend that piece so thank you
so much Ross for this I invite you all
to the reception thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]